- [Man] What is the one element
of traditional corporate culture
you can erase that gets in the
way of developing startups?
- [Gary] You know, politics.
VaynerMedia in the last five
years, I've grown the company
quite a bit so
we're very fortunate.
Whether it is Under Armour,
Pepsi or Turner, GE we're
working with the biggest brands
in the world and one thing
that's holding them
all back is politics.
The game is built where people's
vested interests are not aligned
with the organization's.
Their bonusing people and
they're were rewarding people on
a very certain task that is
completely against investing
three to five years from now.
Every decision is predicated,
especially in big companies,
on 90 day terms.
Because you're in a Wall Street
world where every 90 days they
judge you and all the money that
everybody has humans from the
CEO down are involved in
is the actual stock price.
And if the stock price
goes down people get sad.
If you look at what Jeff Bezos
does and even Mark Zuckerberg to
a degree but not as well as
Bezos in my opinion is they
completely disregard
Wall Street
and they're willing
to have wild swings.
But then you look up every three
to five years and
things are phenomenal.
The thing that holds them back
is the scoring system they've
created for themselves which
is they're in 90 day terms.
And there's nothing that
makes sense to invest in startup
culture, VR like Scoble just
showed you, no company's going
to invest in that 'cause
that's 90 days away from today.
That's not real in 90 days.
That's real in two years,
five years, nine years.
And so for me, a lot of
entrepreneurs and me, myself
I've been successful because
I mentioned earlier it's gonna
probably end up being the theme
of this which is I plan on doing
business for the next 40 years
so why wouldn't
I bring you value?
Corporations are stuck they're
being financially rewarded in
90 day windows which is the
antithesis to investing in
where the world's going.
Shit is deep, right?
(audience laughter)
But it's just the truth.
People in here and I saw people
shaking their heads and I love
that I can see you guys the
people that have been in it they
know this truth.
Which is smart people may not
agree with what they're doing
but they're doing it because
their money is tied up in that.
I have clients tell me every day
that they wish they could take
the money from a television
commercial and put into Facebook
video 'cause they believe me but
they can't because the way it's
scored inside their organization
they would be vulnerable if they
ran Facebook over television
so if the brand goes down and
doesn't do well as long as
they're running TV they're safe.
But if there were to take a
chance and run television, run
Facebook and the business went
down even if it had nothing to
do with Facebook or TV part
they would be vulnerable to lose
their job and I don't blame them.
They have mortgages,
they have kids support,
they have their lives.
They're not being put in a
position to take risks whereas
in my life, entrepreneur land,
everything on my shoulders,
everything on me, I'm only
being rewarded to take risk.
- So all that what the tipping
point for dollars to quit
getting pissed way
into television?
- Death.
When these companies die,
guys, big companies die.
There's a lot of people in this
room that remember Sears being
number one retailer in America.
There's a lot of people in
this room that remember tons of
things being number one and
are no longer number one.
Back to tech, we all remember
Yahoo being number one or
Microsoft being
number one, IBM.
This is what happens.
Big companies go out of business
and then a new regime comes and
they win because they took
advantage of the arbitrage of
marketing or innovation that was
underpriced while the incumbent
was spending money on overpriced
activities or infrastructure so
this is just the way
capitalism has always been.
I always laugh when people say,
I'm not saying anything interesting.
I may say it interesting with a
little bit of flair and a little
big of Jersey and a little bit
of cursing but if you break down
what I talk about,
it's super tried and true.
It's just super tried and true.
When I predicted three years
ago that everybody would use
Snapchat and
everyone's like no way.
That was just me doing the
same thing doing what I do with
Facebook eight years earlier,
right, which was when there's
enough people of enough people,
if there's enough people, enough
13 to 18-year-olds using the
same thing, if a platform ever
wins an entire generation it
will drag everybody else down
into it.
And so Twitter
never did that, right?
Other platforms never
did that but Snapchat did.
Two-and-a-half, three years ago
every single 14 to 18-year-old
was on it which meant which
it was just a matter of time.
So I think I get a lot of credit
for common sense which I'll
gladly take and keep giving it
to me but I don't think it's all
that complicated sometimes.
I think what I do well and what
allows me to sit here and have
people want to take pictures
and be nice to me is the one
difference I think I have from
a lot of people in this room is
I'm not romantic about
how I make my money.
And let me be very
clear about this.
I won email marketing in
1997 for Wine Library.
I didn't want email to get
spammed out and
not be as effective.
It's what made me all my money.
But in 1999, in 2001, in 2003
when all these other people
started doing email marketing
and I saw the conversion rates
coming down and I saw the
Web 2.0 coming up I was okay to
kill myself and my own business
models 'cause that's much more
interesting than having
somebody else do it for you.
Right?
I, as a lot of you know,
really did well on Twitter.
That was my coming-out party.
I had a million followers on it.
I wasn't excited about what I
saw in 2011 and '12 that it was
starting to lose it's attention.
That when I would tweet less
people would convert into just
the awareness or a sale
or whatever I was up to.
So I started investing in other
platforms like Instagram and
paying attention to Snapchat.
A lot of you in the tech space
you know this I was really
at the height of Twitter, right?
I had it.
That wasn't fun for me but I
was willing to put myself out of
business and spend more
time on other platforms
because I saw it coming.
I think the biggest mistake
people do as they try to hold
onto something that
doesn't exist anymore.
And that has been a very
big factor in my career.
- That's a perfect transition
to a question from Robin Hunt
with Big Data Solutions.
Technology changes so much
there's always a learning curve
how do you self scout,
self teach yourself to
be ahead of the curve?
- By doing it.
Meaning I just do it.
We know that
Pokémon Go is happening.
Right?
We know it's
happening right now.
You can say it's a fad or it's
stupid or who cares I need to
understand it not because I care
if Pokémon Go will be here in
three years but because
this is the coming out for AR.
A million apps are
being developed right now.
Literally all of Silicon Valley
is sitting in board rooms right
now creating their AR app and
we're all going to shop and go
to football games and do all
sorts of stuff through that
environment.
You have to use it.
The reason I did well on Vine
and Snapchat was because of
SocialCam.
How many of you nerds
remember SocialCam?
Raise your hands.
Good, six of us.
(audience laughter)
SocialCam was an app that
was hot for like 47 seconds.
It was vigged by the Facebook
newsfeed, it got millions of
users, I jumped on it, I used
it a bunch and then it died.
It died the way that Plurk died.
It died the way that
Vine in some ways has.
Things come and go but I'm not
crippled by putting in the work
because that understanding is
then applied on something else.
There's people in here
that are like
I'm never going to do
anything with Pokémon Go.
That's fine but you're going to
do something with AR
and so you need to use it.
It's like trying to
run a marathon
without prepping for it.
You're gonna lose.
And a lot of you are losing
opportunity and success because
you're not anticipating what the
next chess move is even though
I didn't grow up in the era
of Pokémon and I'm not as
emotional about
those characters,
I mean I know Pikachu
that's where it ends.
(audience laughter)
And my brother grew up with it
and he loves and he's using it.
I don't care about the
entertainment value, I care
understanding the consumer
and human behavior around it.
- As a startup founder how do
you maintain a positivity and a
healthy culture through the
different stages of growth
especially when it's
fast-paced growth?
- Vayner went from 30 to 650
people in four years and from
one to five offices including
London and the way I've kept
culture is dictatorship.
(audience laughter)
It's just the thing that
I care about the most.
Here's how you keep culture when
Kristin in the office is upset
about something and I'm on my
way from Connecticut in to
New York to do a new business
pitch potentially worth
$5 million and I detour
and skip that pitch to
go and talk out
with her that issue,
that's how you maintain culture.
Guys, life's very simple.
There's the things you wish you
were doing, there's the things
you're saying that
you're doing and
then there's the things
that you actually do.
The way you maintain culture is
the same answer as the question
prior to this.
You do it in your actions.
I don't meet with every single
employee that works for me for
10 minutes three months in to
check the box and seem like a
personal CEO.
I do it because in those 10
minutes I want to create some
sort of connection that makes
them feel comfortable to say hi
to me to in the elevator or
to come with a problem to me.
I do it because I asked them
where their hometown is so I can
make a joke about the Cleveland
Indians in the elevator to show
them that I was
paying attention.
I do it because I want to know
if they have siblings how they
roll what interests are they in
because if I want to surprise
and delight them because they're
crushing it that I can get them
Coachella tickets, right?
I do it 'cause it has purpose.
I maintain culture very simply
dictatorship, my actions, and
the number one and two other
options are meritocracy,
letting talent speak for itself
and then finally firing
the most talented people
if they're not willing to care
about their teammates more
than them
thinking they're fancy.
My ego is so big that I don't
think I need anybody that works
for my company and so thus
they're all expendable if
they're not willing to treat
each other with respect and love.
- And I hear you talk a lot
about, I think one of the
reasons they respect you,
follow you as a leader
is because you
are a practitioner.
You're in the trenches.
- I stand in front of the 500 or
so 25-year-olds and I'm like the
best at social media
in this office, right?
And I mean it.
And that's because I
use it more than they do.
They're using it to hook
up, I'm trying to sell shit.
(applause and laughter)
And I mean that.
I think what's interesting about
that is where I got really lucky
with VaynerMedia and I don't
know how you feel about your
agency but what happened for
me is I don't care about the
creative, it's subjective.
I don't care about the awards.
I don't want to
win a Cannes Lion.
I want to sell stuff.
And at some level, somewhere
within the organization
eventually somebody
cares about that too.
You know?
We don't win business because
they care about their job and
they don't want to do
social over TV, respect.
Some people are worried
that I'm too busy
doing other things, respect.
You can think anything but at
the end the day, again, back the
other two things results
are results are results.
We take over Sour Patch Kids
as a client and they become the
fastest-growing
candy in the category.
That's real.
There's no debating.
You didn't like that I cursed
along the way or that we did
some weird new
things, Mazel Tov.
But the fact of the matter
is results are results and so
that's what I live on.
I know what our intent is, we're
not worried about our profit
margin mainly because we think
we're going to get it all at the
end of the day.
Making 8% percent margin on
$400 million is a hell of a lot more
interesting than making
20% on $30 million and
so I'm playing the long game.
I always have.
It's why a lot of you have
good relationships with me.
I see you at different places,
I know who you are, I care,
I interact with you.
Life is simple.
The truth wins.
You may be confused 'cause
times are tough and the media
and there's always issues in
this country and we got flaws
and all that stuff.
You're more than welcome to
look at a pessimistic aspect of
society and life.
I choose to in my 80, 90 years
hopefully on earth to understand
that I got to be a human being
which if you want to talk about
big data and math the rarity of
actually becoming
a person is insane.
And just way too many
people don't understand that and
appreciate it and I do and so
I'm playing the long game
on all this stuff.
- We're pretty lucky.
Pretty lucky.
- Super lucky.
And you live in America?
- Yeah.
- You could have
been a rhinoceros.
(audience laughter)
Or like a tree.
Fucking tree.
Next question from Dan
(inaudible) another local
success story.
On CNBC's "Follow The Leader"
you said nobody outworks me.
- I really believe that.
- I do too.
- How do you maintain that
without exhausting or killing
all of those around you?
- Oh, that's a great question.
Overcommunitcating.
It just comes to communication.
I have to talk
with Lizzie a lot.
The kids are getting older.
I do think, I do think this will
be I'm getting into the end of
an era like 17 and 18 hour
days because my children are now
seven and four and they're just
more stuff that comes along with
that so I think that's
fine and that's great
but it comes down
to communication.
I think people talk about work
life balance a lot, ever since I
started doing DailyVee, which is
my video vlog daily kind of vlog
thing, and Snapchat I think
a lot of you have followed me
for several years have started
really realizing I wasn't joking
that I was working this much.
I think prior when I would talk
about hustle I think people were
like yeah he works hard but when
you get to see that it's fully
documented and there's no
cheating and I'm working 7 AM to
midnight every single day, every
single day, every single minute
it becomes intimidating.
It's my natural just like some
of your some of very smart and
some of you are very pretty and
some of you are very funny
it's my natural state to
hustle that hard.
Not being born this country,
coming up with nothing,
feeling guilty that you have
certain talents, there's a million
reasons that it drives me.
But what I love about
this question is
it's not how do I do it
it's how do I keep the people
around me in a healthy place.
- And how does that happen?
- It's a super
intense thing, man.
I never judge
anybody's work life balance.
As a matter of fact here's a
good opportunity for me,
I always want to clear this up,
I don't think you
should work 15 hours a day.
I think if you're, here's my
punchline if you're complaining
about your life, you need to
look at what you're doing.
So for example, I have friends
that are making hundreds of
millions of dollars in their
careers and tens of million
dollars a year and they're
complaining that they're not
spending enough
time with their family,
then spend time
with your family, dick.
(applause and laughter)
And then I have people
emailing me every
day complaining that their
business is not taking off and
I go do one quick Twitter
search and they're 6 PM tweet is
hitting the links
with my buddies.
You're not going to win and
build a big business if you're
watching "Game of Thrones" and
playing Pokémon Go all day.
Nobody's won on just talent.
Hard work is part
of the equation.
I don't judge anybody.
I think I get judged 'cause
I put myself out there and then
I deserve to be judged and when
people hit me up and say
you're gonna regret this,
you're gonna regret this
and I get that.
I get those emails.
I reply all the time, I'm
like you don't know me.
I respect why you're saying that
because one thing that some of
you who really follow me know is
my wife and I have decided not
to share our
family life on social.
So unlike a lot of my tech
friends who use the cute
pictures of their kids to
get more likes on their social
media, I'm not interested in
doing that with my children.
I'm going to let them decide.
Misha's already, I think
she's gonna have a
YouTube show in a week.
It seems like she
wants to do that, great.
But I don't want to do that and
so it feels even more extreme,
right?
I always ask people that really
call me out on it I'm like if
you're paying attention to me
so much why haven't you noticed
that I put out zero Snapchat
content over the weekends.
Why don't you
really pay attention?
What do you think I'm doing
between 6 PM and 9 PM
when you see nothing?
I'm documenting
every moment I'm in it.
I'm spending far less family
time than most but there's a
whole 'nother
aspect of family time.
I have a lot of friends
from high school that like to
critique me because it's the
ying and yang of yeah, you're
making money but
I'm a family man.
And I say to them I'm like cool
but I know you and you come home
at 6 o'clock at night and you go
to your man cave and drink six
Budweiser's and go
to sleep so fuck you.
(laughter and applause)
So, just 'cause you're
in the same house
as your children
doesn't mean your parenting.
- Amen on that.
- Yeah.
- So have you started, I know
for a while you've been talking
about hustling until 6 PM going
home for three hours and then
getting back after.
Have you enacted that?
- Yeah so this September and
honestly it doesn't feel good to
me right now, I don't feel like
I'm ready for it but I'm really
trying to sell myself which is
I'm saying publicly to come home
during the weekday, I'm such a
momentum guy, you know, I'm so
momentum oriented so the thought
of coming home at six
in the middle of my day
and that's my middle day and
spend an hour with the kids and
then kind of switch the brain to
be in kids mode school, what's
going on in the world, and then
reset back to being back and
trying to stab people in the
face and win is hard but
I'm gonna have to pull it off.
It's important to me I'm getting
a lot of time with my kids on
the weekends and we're taking
a lot of vacation time now.
I'm really in a much better
place than I was several
years ago but I'm feeling
uncomfortable with the
idea of how consistently I can
go four or five days in a
row with being in New York
seeing them zero.
It just doesn't feel as right as
it did 18 months ago,
12 months ago.
I'm a smoke than
fire guy, right?
What I'm doing right now is I'm
selling myself more than telling
you a story this is
something I want to do.
And so I'm beating on my
own brain to get there.
- It goes back to what you said
too, switching your mindset from
business mode to family mode a
lot of times if you're at the
house from 6 to 9 but
you're not present--
- This is happening all day.
I think what you're sensing
and I'm sure a lot of you don't
deeply know me, I'm very
comfortable in my own skin.
I'm comfortable with my
politically correct shortcomings
because it is my life and my
kids' life and my wife's life.
I know what's happening
inside our four walls.
I just wish more people
would feel comfortable.
I think if you're happy
so much more happens.
So I know a lot of people,
this one woman is the CEO of a
company that I
invested in, she's amazing.
She feels the need to check the
box to the world, to her mother,
to her friends that she comes
home and spends
more time with her family.
But every minute she's in that
house I'm getting emails from
her on questions
about the business.
She's not there and I told her
and she's not perfectly happy
because of it 'cause she
doesn't want to be home.
She wants to be
running her business.
She loves her family, she
just on fire and she wants it.
And so I don't think people
understand how long-term life is.
There's a lot of
different ways to do it.
Everybody has her own way.
You're looking at a kid, not
anymore, but you're looking at a
guy whose dad I didn't see from
the ages of seven until 14 ever.
My parents were together it's
just that he left before I woke
up and he came home after I went
to sleep and I love my dad more
than breathing.
Me and my dad have it awesome.
I think we've gotten into a very
hard-core politically correct
zone where for some reason
between social media and just
the topics of the day everybody
wants to impose their point of
view of the world on other
people and I think that's stupid.
(applause)
So on the work life balance
thing, I've got my thing.
It's what feels right.
I think everybody in here has
to keep themselves happy first,
then you can make
other people happy.
And it evolves and it changes.
I'm not convinced that I might
not just one year wake-up and
just check out for a year.
Just 'cause I might.
Just I don't know.
It's funny to me that it runs
through my head sometimes maybe
in-between businesses
if something happens.
I don't know.
But right now I can tell you
hustling, producing for my
family, producing for myself,
producing for my employees and
my team and producing
content for you guys
I'm as happy as it gets.
- Awesome.
Let's talk about
Birmingham for a second.
- Okay.
- This question comes from
Michael Gerard executive vice
president TechLinks what is
the one thing we can do here in
Birmingham as a community to
grow the technology community?
What local entities
need to be involved?
What can we do to
make it be successful?
- You need a win.
And what I mean by a win
I mean not win you need a win.
And so, I think a lot of
communities, and I've spent a
lot of time, obviously we
opened an office in
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
I helped kick off Big Omaha.
It was a canceled conference that
I committed to and it's gone
on to become a big deal.
I got email from a kid yesterday
in Oklahoma City 'cause I went
there in 2009 that a bunch of
leaders in the market said holy
crap wait a minute we all
started our business after that
Gary V talk.
Bringing in Scoble and
things of that nature,
this is unbelievably important.
So many more people are asking
me about questions about you
guys today, right now, on social
why are you there
and what's going on?
But you don't need to bring
anybody me, Scoble, anything the
real win for any community is
you need to support each other
and get a win.
A company coming from this town
that makes a global or at least
a national impact on the scene
is what it takes to take a city
and put it on the map.
That's just the truth.
- We need a big exit.
- Look, LA was a, it's not that
you need a big exit and
I don't want to play the VC game.
You don't need a big round,
you need a big impact, right?
Need a big impact.
Guys, Snapchat coming out of LA
has changed LA tech and
LA is a big city. Right?
But these things matter.
GoDaddy in Arizona,
these things matter.
Even Dowalla a lot of these
companies start in places,
what you need to figure out,
what the city needs to figure
out is I'm positive and
you guys know me
I'm not pandering to you I don't
give a shit how you feel about
me, I'm positive that something
amazing will come out of here.
My concern is as soon as it
starts happening you're going to
move to San Francisco.
And that's what happens.
Facebook was started in Boston.
Pinterest was
started in Pennsylvania.
The key is not only to fester
the community to help each other
tech wise, marketing wise to
have a win but then what can you
guys do from a city and state
level to make that person or
that team want to ground
themselves here for the long
haul and everybody that comes
a smaller town than a top-five
city always feels like they have
to go to one of those cities to
make it because of the tech
talent or the venture capital.
I believe that to not be
true any more because the
infrastructure around the
internet marketing world today.
That's the truth.
You can do a lot of events, you
can do a lot of marketing, but
what you need is a win.
- We need a win.
- And I think if you get really
back to the opening line here
today 51-49, giving more to
others, if you've got a business
in this community that is not
a direct competitor of your
business and you have more
marketing chops or you have more
technical chops cross
pollinating and helping each
other is exactly what
small towns can do better than
big towns and I highly recommend
that southern hospitality that
is deeply rooted in your DNA to
begin with that you figure out
how to use that in a business
environment as well because the
impact of one of those people
popping and winning will have a
bigger ROI on your
business as a halo effect
than if you do it separately.
- That's awesome.
(applause)
- It's true.
And you know it's cool of being
here it's true thanks for the
claps but what's even more
interesting is I think it's,
back to stereotypes, I think
it's more natural in you.
I can tell you right now there's
not a lot of people from Jersey
that are just
going to hook it up.
I do think that you should take,
I think everybody should bet on
their strengths and I think that
sense of community that you guys
have is very real and you should
take full advantage of it.
And I think the entrepreneurs in
the audience get into the sharp
elbows entrepreneur DNA and
leave a little bit of that DNA
of southern hospitality on the
side and I actually think they
should go
completely the other way.
- Yeah, culturally we have a lot
of advantages because that is
the culture.
- 100%.
- And technology makes it where
you can level the playing field
from Birmingham, Alabama.
- 'Cause it's leveled.
I think there's a lot of things.
I think it's just momentum.
Again being somebody who's
kicked off and been at the
inaugural conference of a lot
of small cities by comparison to
New York, San Francisco it's
stunning what something just
like this that's unbelievable.
I'm so proud to be here.
I definitely think with all
the stories I get to tell my
children and grandchildren one
day the fact that during this 20
year era that I went and used my
micro-fame within the community
to go to places that were
not New York and LA and
San Francisco and in any small
part because I'm just flying
through it's you guys, it's you
guys that are actually making it
happen but to even be .0001 of
the narrative of being at the
first conference, bending
changing my schedules, doing it
for less, all those things it
feels nice and
I'm proud of that.
- Cool.
Let's get back into--
(applause)
agency grind,
the VaynerMedia grind.
- Okay.
- This question's from Alex
Kistler what are a few ways that
you mentioned meetings are
quick efficient lively amongst
clients, internally,
employees and clients?
- If I'm in them
they're all that.
So that's easy.
After that, the
truth is I don't.
I hope through osmosis and
people seeing how I want them.
I have three-minute
meetings with people.
I think the number one flaw in
client services is you book a
30 minute meeting it's actually
eight minutes of work but since
your Google calendar says it's
30 you just are a human and you
waste 22 minutes.
I'm big on four-minute,
seven-minute,
11 minute meetings.
AJ is the best at this he tried
to mandate it and cut things.
I think that I try to inspire
it through my own actions.
I'm very aware of human
tendencies and
shortcomings and you
just try to bring it up
every so often but it's a
very difficult challenge.
I think most
humans are just
not smart with their
time management.
- Next question from Jacob
(inaudible) what has caused the
rise in live streaming media
while the market has shifted to
delayed consumption
like Netflix, Hulu?
- There's two
micro kind of trends.
They both work.
I always say to people I really
believe that you will watch
a 5 1/2 hour movie.
I think that if, how many people
here if the next Star Wars is
5 1/2 hours would be thrilled to
go watch it, raise your hands?
That's insane.
(audience laughter)
Five and half hours.
Nerds.
I've run there opening night.
Midnight to 5 in the
morning and go to work. In.
I think great content can make
somebody watch for 5 1/2 hours.
I also know there's a ton of
people in here that stopped
watching a six second
Vine after three seconds.
The length of your content is
not the variable of its quality.
And so, we're gonna always want
watch two hour movies and
one hour TV shows.
But we also want to
watch live streaming.
So there just two
different macro trends.
I don't that
they're conflicting.
I think one thing we have to
recognize is we only have 24
hours in a day and so if
you're allocating three, six,
whatever hours to entertainment
they may come in the form of
Netflix, they may come in the
form of live streaming,
they may come in the form of
searching Instagram all day.
It's incredible
the length of time some of
you are spending in Snapchat
stories, right?
I think the bigger issue at hand
is that the cell phone is just
so much the remote
control of our lives.
And I think sooner than later
will control we watch
on TV more and more.
Obviously things like augmented
reality definitely social and
video in there.
What's allowing it is
just tech infrastructure.
As Wi-Fi gets stronger, as
bandwidth gets stronger and more
powerful and you're not
buffering when you're watching
high quality video from the
over the top networks it's time,
right?
And so, back to Star Wars I flew
from New York to LA and watched
somebody sitting next to me
watch the entire latest
Star Wars on their phone
on the flight out.
And why I thought that was
super important is everybody in
Hollywood's like no big theaters
and you need the right set,
this guy watched it
on his phone.
People grossly underestimate
how much we love the story.
We love production, we love
a lot of things but we love
stories.
And stories can
come in any form.
I broke out on YouTube in 2006
doing a show called
Wine Library TV
and I don't know, how many
of you ever saw Wine Library TV?
(light applause)
Thank you.
Thanks mom.
(audience laughter)
And so as some of
you might remember
I look like a hostage
in the Middle East.
There was no audio.
I never wore a mic.
There was no lighting.
It wasn't the production
value that made it work.
It was the content that
was coming out of my mouth.
And so I think that we get
caught up way too, so many
people get caught up in
the production value.
And look, DRock's come into my
life and clearly has taught me
there's plenty of
value in that as well
but it's not an either/or.
And you don't have to
do both every time.
And so I don't think there's
anything without the story.
If the story blows you don't
care about the special effects.
- At your core is that
what you are, a storyteller?
- 100%, 100%.
Whether I was storytelling the
wines of New Zealand, Australia
and Spain before
anybody in America.
Where I was story telling me
and whether I'm storytelling
businesses around me
that's exactly what I am.
And for me I got lucky because
I think the world in a direction
that matched my natural
skill set and storytelling.
I'm comfortable in very
fast off-the-cuff
raw, real, authentic.
It's matched me so I'm very
grateful to be born in this era
because I wasn't moving to
Hollywood in 1974 to make it.
Right?
I was 32 years old,
I was 31 years old when
I started Wine Library TV.
It was the first time I ever
made the video for the world.
I wasn't in the mindset of I'm
going to become a personality.
I'm a businessman.
Who happens to be a
little bit charismatic.
- So as a storyteller
do you think,
you say you
day trade attention--
- Yes.
- is that an evolution
of the storytellers
just in today's market?
- To be a great storyteller
can't just be great at the story
you have to understand where
it's being distributed and how.
Way too many storytellers
stink at the context
part of storytelling.
You have to know where
it is being delivered.
What I have done very well and
when I say I day trade attention
it's back to me
not being romantic.
I follow you.
I don't get to say that
Twitter lasts forever.
Netflix lasts forever.
I'm just paying attention to
your eyes and ears and
I'm watching you
24/7/365.
(audience laughter)
And while so many of
you talk about what
you're not gonna do, I make
bets on what you're gonna do.
How may people here thought or
said in the last three years
that they were not going
to ever be on Snapchat?
Snapchat was stupid, it was for
kids sexting, raise your hands.
Raise 'em high.
Of people those people how
many of you are now on Snapchat?
That's what I do for a living.
- Alright.
This question is from Aaron
Albright talking about Snapchat
what are your thoughts
on the memories feature?
- Love it.
- Does it add to, does it take
away or add from the sort
of in the moment?
- Guys, it's going to be the same
game forever all of these things
start as a niche, Facebook's
a college social network.
Snapchat is
disappearing content.
Musical.ly is dubbing music
songs and things of that nature
then they hit scale and then
they give you every feature
because they go from being a
niche app to being
a content platform. Got it?
Rinse and repeat.
Rinse and repeat in nine years
I'll be credit for being right about
Smooga but all I did was
deploy that thesis.
Meanwhile everyone's like this
is what now ruined Snapchat.
The memories feature just
like newsfeed ruined Facebook.
(laughter)
- How'd that work out?
- Great for Facebook,
shitty for that person that's
wrong on the record you can
Google it and see that
they were fucking wrong.
(laughter)
- Are you seriously are you,
I hear you're a businessman
and we like you say that.
We know you are a businessman
but you are equally motivated,
in my opinion, not only by the
game, earning, hustling but also
by being right.
Talk about that for a second.
- Dammit.
Yeah.
And honestly I'm not proud of it
is quite vain and not super,
I don't think it's a good trait
but boy am I driven by saying
I told you so.
And it's just the truth.
I'm really truly not proud of
it. I actually don't think it's
a very attractive characteristic
but I get off on it.
I do.
I love, I love
being underestimated.
I hated Tiger Woods then America
hated him then I loved him.
I love underdogs.
I'm an underdog,
I loved when I got into
VaynerMedia and Adweek wrote
Twitter boy is coming
to the agency world.
Let's see how that works out.
I'll tell you Adweek how
that worked out,
I fucking destroyed everybody.
(laughter and applause)
A very funny thing
happened in the
liquor business when I got
involved in my dad's business a
bunch of sons had come into
the businesses of a lot of other
liquor store owners about
five years earlier than me.
And they didn't win.
They weren't good.
And so when I came there was
a lot of people were like
oh, here's another one, right?
My dad was part of a group of 10
or 11 guys or gals that had good
stores in New Jersey.
I loved being underestimated.
I loved when all those people
told me to open a second liquor
store instead of this fad
internet thing that I'm doing.
Right?
I love that.
I live for that.
As a matter of fact, the reason,
why do you think
I opened VaynerSports?
I don't think CAA and Rock
Nation are worried about me
right now.
But they will be.
- That's what I was
about to ask you.
Does that, you think about
Drew Rosenhaus sitting there.
- I'm going to kill Drew.
Now, now you have to understand
something if Drew is good
enough, this is how I think
about life, I want to build the
biggest building in town.
Got it?
I want to build the biggest
building in town so when I say
I'm going to kill Drew
I don't want to kill him.
I mean I want to win.
I want to build the
biggest building in town.
However, the reason I think that
I'm likable in business circles
of people that really know me is
here's my thesis on building the
biggest building in town: by
going out and building the
biggest building in town.
If you look very carefully at
a lot of other business people
their theory on big building in
town is by tearing down all the
other buildings around them.
If you understand that little
story you'll understand me
completely and you'll understand
my belief of what a purebred
entrepreneur is.
I want everybody to win.
I want Drew's business
to get 10 times bigger.
I want all of you to build
bigger businesses than me but I
want to build a bigger business
than you and what I love about
America is for all of our
shortcomings this is still the
best playing field to let
meritocracy rule
and I love that.
And I love that feeling.
And when--
(applause)
And when my homie
Travis from Uber and
when my homie Chris Sacca
becomes the best VC and goes on
"Shark Tank" and they beat me
I'm the most pumped for them,
they deserve it.
And then I say but
it's not over yet.
And that's who I am.
- Awesome.
This question comes from Tucker
Austin BBVA Compass where do you
see social media going next?
Can we do this in Birmingham,
can we do this
here once and for all?
There's no social media.
It is a slang term
for the internet.
(laughter)
Tell me what social media is.
People call Pokémon Go social
media, there is no social media.
Robert, we called it Web 2.0.
Robert wrote blog posts, so
did I that said Web 2.0 site
Facebook looks really good.
There is no social media.
It is a slang term to make it
easy for us to refer to certain
things but I don't
know where is it going?
It's the internet and the
internet is going in a lot of
places and a lot of things are
happening but what we want to
always stay in touch with each
other at scale and communicate
with each other
and produce content?
The answer is yes and whether
that goes on the internet and
goes into a VR environment or
something we can't think of
today the answer is yes.
We like to
communicate with each other.
We drew pictures in the side of
a cave, we stood on mountains
and made smoke
signals, we communicate.
It's what we do.
It's never going away.
- Awesome.
(audience laughter)
I think you just killed social
media in Birmingham, Alabama.
- I love it.
It's just a term.
- This question's from
Jennifer Skjellum president of
Tech Birmingham who you met.
- Yes. Awesome.
- As a very self-aware person
with thick skin how do you
determine what that react to
and what people or comments you
actually take to
heart versus blinders?
- That's a really
interesting question.
The truth is I think it's
complete serendipity and
randomness.
Sometimes the day of the week,
the moment for example I'm quite
testy after a New York Jets
loses so if I think about my
scrum up on social a lot of
them happen on Sunday night.
It's random.
Here's what I would say, I think
most people are
unbelievably awesome.
I'm the most bullish
person on human beings.
Again, it's becoming a more of
an intense feeling because were
living through a tough time in
the US where I think that we
have to look at
ourselves really long and hard.
We've got real issues and
I believe in those issues.
I do believe they're issues.
However, I think we have to
take it at a macro level.
It is stunning that
we are still here.
We invented bombs that
wipe us completely out.
We invented bombs that wipe us
completely out a long time ago.
A half a century ago.
What's that?
- [Man 2] And we actually
have enough to do it.
- Right.
Right.
So the fact that we're here
I'm a big fan that
human beings are
the number one
underrated thing in the world.
We're gonna spend all of our
time talking about those small
percentage that creates terrible
things like what happened in
France and Dallas and the
individual cops that
do these bad things.
I understand why and they
populate as our main stories but
I'm bullish on human beings and
so the things that I react to
are the following.
There's a lot of people that say
things about me because
I've put myself out there.
Most of them I have a lot of
empathy to why they think that.
They didn't like my
ego in that moment.
They didn't like
something I said.
They didn't like the
confrontational aspect of my
East Coast Jersey thing
and I think they're right.
So it's very easy when somebody
takes a shot at me that for me
understand where
they're coming from.
The things that I sometimes
engage with is when I think the
intent was really mean.
Bad, like evil.
I think 99.999% of things that
are said about me that I don't
like come from a good place.
It's that person's point of view
on me and I'm very empathetic.
I think once in a while
somebody comes along and is just
genuinely dark in the core and
I want to fight that was some
light in return.
And usually I start
with understanding.
Some people just really, you
know, I don't know it's actually
very easy for me.
You know?
- You've talked about EQ.
- IQ is decreased in value
because of technology
but EQ is greater than ever.
Emotional intelligence really,
really matters and I look for
that in anybody that I
surround myself with.
Do you actually have empathy and
gratitude and self-awareness and
care and all these warm and
fuzzy things that I think are
the essential infrastructure
to be successful in business.
- You want other people to be
big fans of humanity as well?
- Yeah, you know, I'm gonna
struggle to the day I die of
allowing yourself to
look at glass half empty.
I just feel like I feel like now
I understand it's DNA and its
wiring and if you grew up with a
mother who's extremely negative
it's a really tough
situation to break out of.
It's just proven.
I've understood.
You grow up in a
tough town, I get it.
There's a couple of issues with
that, number one, nobody cares.
That's the big punchline.
Everybody's got stuff.
The problem is nobody cares.
And once you understand
that nobody cares and you're
complaining to empty air you
start going in a little bit of a
different direction.
Yeah, I like
putting out positivity.
I like that, I love that my
trainer Mike who spent the last
two years with me is going
through some weird depression
thing right now 'cause is not
around me 24/7 and he's like
I miss the positivity.
That's a good thing and I want
other people to have that and I
want other people, you know what
guys, I want to say something
right now. Getting a little
bit of a bigger plane.
What's happening right now in
tech, in business and society is
the small minority of people
that are mad and angry and
hateful and dark are much louder
than the big percentage of us
that are happy and excited and
feel great and because the way
technology works they are much
louder than they
had ever been before.
And so I feel like as somebody
who's got full of bright light
and happiness that I need to
start getting louder about that
as well 'cause that the only
way were going to combat it.
(applause)
And you know what?
That right there in real time is
what it's all about because if
that's the thing that's gonna
get the loudest claps so far
from this conversation that's
what we need to be focusing on.
And this is something
I'm focusing on inside of
VaynerMedia and this is
something I'm focusing with all
my friends and this is
something I want to bring to
this network.
Listen, let me be really blunt
with you over the last five
years until about 18 months ago
when I came back out with a lot
of content for three years there
I was fairly quiet for me if
anybody's been following me
since 2006 it's because I didn't
want to be a
motivational speaker.
I didn't like the part that made
people rah-rah because I was so
proud that I can actually build
businesses and I think the thing
that a lot of people look at
when they see motivational
speaker is there's fluff behind
and a lot of times are bad
behind it and I wanted to
disassociate myself
from that world.
But I feel more responsibility
than ever as somebody who is
happy and wants other people
to be happy, genuinely,
to get louder.
It's an interesting time in our
country's history and just in
human society and so if you
leave with anything, I'll get
you tactics on social you'll
remember Scoble's amazing VR
thing if you leave with anything
for any of us please, please
take on the sense of
responsibility that if you've
got good and you feel good
to start sharing that
content as well.
Because the world
needs more of it.
(applause)
- You mentioned people that have
followed you for a good while
have differently noticed a
change in the tone and more
effort towards being positive
and putting out content that
encourages people
to be positive.
Do you ever get down?
What gets you down?
- [Man 2] The Jets losing?
- (Gary laughs) As long as the 8
to 12 core people in my life are
healthy I struggle
to really get down.
I just don't know how to do it.
Here's the game I play, I'm on
the cover of Time magazine and
it says he did it. Right?
That's me holding
a Jets jersey. Right?
And then I get a phone call and
it's my sister usually, I don't
why, telling me that my mom died
and I'm crushed and I'm so in
tune with my feelings that I
genuinely can get into teared up
devastation mode, my brain, by
the way I think the brain is so
underrated and we
don't know a lot about it.
Seven years ago I decided that
I would never get sick again
and I haven't been sick.
Just a random fun fact.
So the feeling even right now
telling you this story and
not even fully doing it
I don't feel good.
I feel nauseated.
Why would I live my
life any other way?
Why in the world would I live my
life allowing my business wins
and losses to really impact me
anywhere close to the health and
well-being and happiness of
the people that I love the most.
I'm just not capable.
I lose business every day.
I win business every day.
People say I'm the best,
people say I'm full of shit.
All of it happens.
But at the end of the day the
rewards that I'm getting and I'm
getting plenty of them, the
rewards that I'm getting in life
are just massively
secondary to those people.
And that's how I live my life
and so when you live your life
that way losing a big account or
somebody calling you out is just
not that painful.
You just put it in to context.
I usually just take it.
You know, this is so
interesting, I think you'll find
this interesting, my favorite
scene in movies is always when
somebody gets punched in the
mouth and they take the punch,
they spit their tooth out and
then a look back at the other
person, I don't know
if you've seen that.
There's always some
version of that scene.
That's who I am as a
fucking human being.
I'm built to get punched in the
mouth, I'm gonna spit my front
tooth and I'm gonna look right
back at you and be like,
"Now what, bitch?"
(laughter and applause)
That's how I feel about life.
And that's it.
- A lot of folks want to ask you
questions so lets get rolling
with audience participation.
- Awesome.
Let's do it.
You guys ready?
- Who's first?
- Let's do it.
- Scoble.
- And then this guy over here.
- [Robert] On Monday a guy came
up to me after a conference and
said I never met you,
I hear you posted on
being sexually abused.
And that night I had a
discussion with my wife about
being sexually abused.
And I've been thinking about
that conversation ever since.
It's a highly rewarding thing.
How do you get people to
help other people?
(inaudible)
that drug is the strongest
drug I've ever had
and I'm chasing that.
- Yeah.
- [Robert] How do you chase
that as a community?
- I think you and I are
just doing it right now.
The courage for a man to say
he was sexually abused in our
society today is extreme and I
applaud you and these are the
things I try to talk about too.
I made a video Robert about
who are you worried
about letting down.
It was a one the big insights
I figured out on the road.
I like huh people aren't taking
chances not because they're
scared but they're scared
was their mom's gonna think.
They're scared what
their wife's gonna think.
They're scared what their
husband is gonna think if they
fail, when they fail and I made
that video, it's me talking to
somebody in London and I
mean thousands of interactions.
I think the truth is the game.
The truth is live streaming
isn't really ruining America.
America doing the wrong things
hurts America and I'm thrilled.
I'm excited about living over
the next 10 years in society
where we as a society in America
are gonna take one, hear me out
now, a step backwards because
it's time for us to
deal with our issues.
We're gonna take a step
backwards 'cause of
Facebook Live.
We're gonna take a step
backwards but we're gonna take
two steps forward stuff 'cause
the truth is always better.
So I think what we do Robert
is we continue to tell stories
of truth, we continue to tell
our true stories and give other
people courage and
it's a momentum game.
You were able to do that, that
helped that one individual do
that and that's why I'm
spending a lot of time.
I've been spending a lot of time
is inner cities I did a morning
show called The Breakfast Club
a couple months ago that when
extremely viral.
And even looking around seeing
minorities shaking their heads.
It went viral.
The interesting thing is a lot
of people don't know about me is
I went to college with a 90%
African-American college.
I spent a lot of time in that
ecosystem and that is who my
best friends are.
I have a lot of empathy but
still I'm not black, right?
When I went on that show and
is before the flair up that's
happening now, I wasn't talking
about racial issues I just said
nobody cares and it was insane
what's happened in my inbox.
That same thing I just did for
everybody here and said
nobody cares, nobody cares.
Everybody's got shortcomings and
one of things I've told so many
my friends, I always tell
my friends you're right.
I tell all my female
entrepreneurs all the time
you're right.
There's a male
prejudice, you're right.
You're right.
It is harder for
female entrepreneur
to get funding from VCs.
It is harder, it is harder,
it is harder for minorities,
that's true.
But I always ask them now what?
And so I think that we just have
to have more real conversations
instead of just pandering.
I did a conference where
somebody asked me about,
it was a female entrepreneur
conference, I've done a lot of
investing in that demo and they
said Gary is there a difference
between men and women?
And I said yes.
And people got upset.
I was like what the fuck
is the matter with you?
(audience laughter)
There is a difference
between men and women.
I just think that were
in a very funny time.
Look, I think empires fall.
You know I think empires fall?
'Cause all of them have fallen.
And they fall after
too many years of good.
Just want to give you a news
alert if you're under 40,
you've been real privileged.
Your grandpa, my most viral
Instagram post ever
happened the other day.
I think that something like your
grandparents, your complaining
about not getting
a bunch of likes
while your
grandparents went to war.
Right?
We've just gotten soft.
As a collective, you may not be
soft, I definitely don't think
I'm soft but, you know, as a
collective and even I,
you know what, I don't think I'm soft.
It's a lot easier to work
19 hours a day
than live in the Great Depression.
It's a lot easier to work 19
hours a day then be drafted and
going to Europe.
What the fuck is
the matter with us?
It's time for us to reconcile
that we've had two generations,
everyone's like this
generation it's so too bad.
They're gonna be the first
generation that is not going to
have a better life
than their parents.
We deserve it.
We got soft.
The data is pretty clear.
There's a lot more for 13 and
14-year-olds that didn't work in
this last generation than
the generation before it.
Maybe they're too soft 'cause
they went to camp
every fucking summer.
(laughter and applause)
Maybe you're not
winning because your
biggest issues growing up was
you didn't get the new Jordans.
What's the matter with people?
So anyway I don't remember what
the fuck I was talking about
but let's go do shit.
- The guy over here.
- Yeah.
Truths Robert, truths.
Your truth helped that man.
You know what I mean?
I think it helps female
entrepreneurs and minorities
more to say yes there's
a difference, now what?
That a truth.
I wish it wasn't the case but
I only play in the market
that I live in.
You know?
- [Man 3] Hey.
Earlier you said to maintain you
own compass is really important,
right?
- 100% believe in it.
- [Man 3] I think the best way
to do that is to keep utilizing
(inaudible) people and the best
way to maintain happiness,
I think, is to invest in
relationships with others,
right?
- Real quick, real quick.
- [Man 3] Okay.
- That's your DNA.
I can tell you that is
not how my dad rolls.
- [Man 3] Right.
- And my dad's his best when
he does what's best for him.
So I think that idealistically
exactly right and you're looking
at a guy who so thankful that
that's how he's wired but not
everybody's wired that way.
And that self-awareness matters.
And it's important.
- [Man 3] I agree.
The next part of that is being
an entrepreneur is often,
by nature, a selfish
endeavor, right?
- Yep.
- [Man 3] So how do you maintain
being an entrepreneur at the
same time pouring into
others more than
you care about yourself?
- By doing it.
I feel comfortable making
money and being successful.
As comfortable as I am being
there emotionally for others and
doing other things.
By doing both, it's just actions.
Nobody should beat
themselves up
for trying to do
good for themselves.
That's insanity.
And so I'm just comfortable.
On Tuesday I'm just rolling
and selling stuff and making it
happen and winning, yay, right?
DJ Khaled all I do is win,
win, win. Winning, right?
And then on Thursday I go speak
to kids or give back or donate a
bunch of money to
somebody, I don't know.
Every day is different but
I'm not in the business of
critiquing myself.
Here's the problem, my man,
everybody is trying to project
to the world a PR'd
version of themselves.
Do you, do the right thing and
everything has a funny way of
figuring itself out.
Robert was an absolute mainstay
in the world that
I wanted to jump in.
In 2006, I wanted to
be part of Web 2.0.
I was in left field.
They were all in San Francisco
all from Tech TV and blogging.
I had a liquor
store in New Jersey.
What I did was I put my
head down and I worked.
I just worked.
I did smart things, I used the
product better, I gave back to
my and I was
chipping away, chipping away,
chipping away, chipping away.
That's what it is.
How do I reconcile that?
By doing both.
Sometimes I'm selfish
and sometimes I'm not.
And sometimes
I'm selfish for a month
and sometimes
I'm not for a year.
You just roll.
I don't over micro analyze that.
I know what's in my heart and
then I know that if I can map,
the biggest thing I fear is that
I can't match in my actions
the intent in my heart.
I battle for that because if
I can pull that off, I'm good.
All-time good.
Yo, this dude here by
the way also in the hat.
- [Man 4] What I wanted
to ask you answered it.
- Did I?
- [Man 4] Yeah, it's more of a
psychological type question.
Is it the early bird that gets
the worm or is it the bird that
matches the sleep patterns of
the worm who gets the worm?
- Both.
- [Man 4] Okay.
- You know?
There's so many
ways to win. Right?
Look, there's people that have
made the NBA that worked their
face off but had a
little less talent.
And then there's guys that just
had so much God damn talent that
yeah they worked but
there's just so many
different ways to do it.
The key is which bird
knew themselves best.
Got it?
That's the bird.
The bird that's like fuck it my
wings are short but
I'll wake up earlier.
You know?
(audience laughter and applause)
That was good.
This is why DRock's around
when this random shit comes up.
My man.
- [Desmond] Desmond, what's up?
- Desmond.
- [Desmond] There's a lot
of growing undertones of
gentrification
within the city,--
- Yeah.
- I was wondering what is your
opinion on how to close the
disparity gap and how to infuse
more of those entrepreneurial
initiatives in
lower income areas?
- That's a really good question.
Desmond, I did something
really smart three years ago.
I promised myself that I
wouldn't talk about shit
that I don't understand.
As I started going to
conferences and hearing people
talk about social media and
I was like they're wrong.
They're wrong and
they're experts and
they're supposed to be experts.
I don't know is the real
answer to your question.
I mean that.
I have no god damn idea
because I don't understand city
politics, tax, there's a lot
of other things going on.
That don't allow me
to answer your question
as much as I'd like to.
The real answer, and boy
this hurts me, is I don't know.
That being said, I care
about this issue personally.
That's why I went on
"The Breakfast Club."
I care about this and I run
content against minorities
because I want to inspire them
to understand it's not going to
be the town and the
government that's gonna do it.
The second you understand
nobody's gonna do it for you
and you go and do it and then,
listen, here's my
promise about money.
Let me make you one
Money never cares what
the person looks like
that's making them money.
Do you understand?
They don't care.
They just want the money.
And so I think the way we get
female leadership,
minority leadership,
Latino leadership,
all that is just
having more wins.
It's the same answer I
gave you about this town.
How does this town win?
Have a winner.
How do you get more diversity?
You have more people win.
How do you more
diversity in the NBA?
I don't know.
The white kid's got to be good.
(audience laughter)
I don't know.
The market, the one thing,
there's a lot of things in
America, companies, politics,
school organizations a lot of
them that will not allow the
white kid to be in the NBA or
the black kid to be in the
VC but business is different.
The internet did for you.
Right?
The internet did it for me, man.
Everybody thought I was a loser.
I got D's and F's.
I was a loser, immigrant loser
but then the market allowed me
to do me and now
I'm a fucking hero.
Right?
We're all born with different
natural talents and different
things but I think the answer
is predicated on doing it.
That's why I said crap I
don't know how to fix the
gentrification of all those town
this a lot of that going on.
It happened in
Brooklyn, my area.
I don't know that's a little
bit in different plane and I,
I just don't know.
But I know of I get seven kids
to build big businesses
that if they are then examples
for other kids that can look and
be like I look like that
and I can do that.
That's how you have to do it.
That's what I'm trying to do
my little contribution to that
community and those communities
and by the way there's a lot of
poor white and
there's all sorts of stuff.
To me, is actually more of a
financial and opportunity thing.
One of the big things back to
"The Breakfast Club", you talk
about your story, mine's less
noble than yours I talked about
how eBay was an
unbelievable opportunity
for somebody with no money.
Right, go to the dollar store,
go garage saling, buy stuff,
sell it on eBay.
I've gotten thousands in the
last two months of emails and
DRock's shaking his head because
he sees them just ungodly,
you can go to Twitter
and search my name.
Go search my name GaryVee and
eBay 'cause I want you to see it,
it's crazy.
People literally tweeting things
like I make $200 a week,
this is very really needing
money and I made $400
this weekend selling on eBay.
Unbelievable stuff.
I think it's just, I'm a
motivator and I can some reason
get people to do stuff and
people that are not hungry or
not as hungry.
All shapes and sizes go and do.
I don't know how to answer your
question for this but here's
what I can tell you.
If you build the best company
this town, Silicon Valley,
New York City, they'll take you.
- [Man 5] Gary,
(inaudible) Iron Truck Fitness.
I've watched your
fitness journey--
- Yes.
- [Man 5] over
the last few years.
I gotta assume but I would love
to hear you elaborate on that
18-hour hard work before
are not as productive as
18-hour hard work now
because of your fitness journey.
So I want you to explain that if
it's true and then maybe talk to
the entrepreneurs in this room
about how important it is to
have a culture of health and
wellness in their business.
- It's not true.
(audience laughter)
You're asking the question and I'm
like, ugh, this guy seems like
such a guy. This is gonna suck.
(audience laughter)
I will tell you that
my energy level is
exactly the same but that's
because I think, my big belief
and I should probably do this to
be able to answer this once and
for all, I think I have some
weird chemical imbalance
with adrenaline. Right?
It's just easy for me.
I really
generally don't feel it.
Now, let's keep going.
That's right now.
Do I think it's been smart that
I've lost 40 pounds of fat and
gained 15 pounds of
muscle in the last 24 months?
Yes, I think the math of that
is gonna work itself out, right?
I think later down the
line I think it's going to be
beneficial for me.
The other thing, my friend,
look, you don't need me to
anoint to this audience, if you
are not common sense enough to
understand physical
health is a good idea
than you've already lost.
Let's just start with that.
Number two, the thing that I'm
actually passionate about in
parallel and a space that I'm
going to be betting on very
heavily financially and
culturally is mental health.
So I'm obsessed with meditation.
I think meditation is going to
be a huge play in the consumer
behavior that we're going to
have a lot more conversations
about the brain over the next 20
and 30 years and I'm excited to
really work on being both
physically and mentally the most
healthy I can 'cause I think
they work more hand-in-hand
than I think people realize.
To finish off your question,
of course I would recommend
everybody to take care
of themselves better.
I'll give you one that is real.
I like the feeling of grabbing
my suitcase off the top of an
airplane 'cause I'm on them
every day and it feels lighter
and my back doesn't hurt.
It feels fun to pick up Xander
and walk eight blocks in
New York City with him here and
his little face next to mine
'cause I can actually hold him
whereas before I could
only go a block.
There's a lot of, I would
tell you that one walk that I'm
referencing where I carried him
for 11 blocks and I got to kiss
his face 40 times was worth
every second that
I've put into health.
(applause)
- [Man 6] Gary?
- Yes?
My man?
- [Man 6] I'm grew up in
New York, big Jets fan.
- I love you.
- [Man 6] (inaudible)
If you owned the Jets--
- When.
- when you own the Jets,--
(applause and laughter)
how much do
you pay Ryan Fitzpatrick?
- In this situation right now?
- [Man 6] In this situation but
put it on the other hand,
you're his agent,
how much you ask for?
- It's an interesting question.
This very nerdy.
This is probably interesting for
four you, I'll try to go fast.
(audience laughter)
So if you're as big of a Jets
fan as I am the Jets are in
trouble because they don't
have a lot of young talent.
They've invested all
on the defensive line.
I just saw texts as
I was getting on here
that Moe Wilkerson
just got a big contract
which Moe is literally probably
my favorite Jet and I'm
against that signing because I
don't think you pay that kind of
money for defensive
lineman in today's NFL.
I would pay Fitz as the Jets
owner for the next two years
because there's enough,
they have some
chance of a miracle
Super Bowl run if there's a
lot of injuries with
Brandon Marshall.
with Revis, with Decker,
they're top heavy with
older guys so here's
what I would say to you.
I would sign Fitz to a two-year
deal and pay him 12, 14, fine.
His agent is asking for that
range fine or and I'd have to
really, there's a couple things
I don't know how healthy are my
old guys this and that.
There's probably couple things
that I don't have
a data point on.
There's only one thing, there's
only two moves for them:
either sign Fitz for two years
and try to hope to
hell there's enough
injuries that lets you sneak in
because the talent is tier two
not tier one to win or blow
the whole thing fuckin' up.
What I'd probably do is
trade Revis and Marshall.
The problem with the NFL is
with a salary cap you don't get
anything for these guys.
What am I going to get for
Revis or Marshall or Decker?
You're gonna get fourth,
fifth, sixth round, it's crazy.
Real talent but the way the cap
is the money against the cap is
too valuable so they're in
the rock and a hard place.
- [Man 7] Hey Gary.
- Hey man, how are you?
- [Man 7] I'm doing well.
Good to see you again.
- Thank you brother.
- [Man 7] I want
your take on something.
I saw a video that you
did a couple weeks ago.
It was kind of spontaneous, this
lady stopped you as you were
getting into an Uber and
I literally when I saw the video
I came out of my chair
I went like this.
(inaudible) I sincerely mean
that but the reason it stood out
to me is a quick background and
I kinda want an inflection
point in your life.
- Yeah.
- [Man 7] So I left the
Marine Corp in 1998,
went to architecture school,
(inaudible)
and had a .com behind it.
- Yes.
- [Man 7] And made
a complete left turn.
- Yes.
- [Man 7] And what did you think
about computers when you never
owned one but I knew that's
a revolutionary moment and
I wanted to be a part of that.
- Same thing happened to me.
Same thing happened to me.
- [Man 7] And so that comment
you made to that lady that spoke
to that moment.
- Real quick just get everybody
aligned, somebody rolled up on
me as we're leaving a
conference, luckily having DRock
around we capture these moments
she came up to me, I roll down
my window, she's like can you
just in my selfie video with me
can you just say three words
that would motivate me forever
or something like that.
I said you're gonna die.
(laughter and applause)
Again, similar to that bird thing
I just said I don't know
where it comes from.
That's what came out of me
but it motivates me every day.
It's funny I think I
really hit that one for me.
That's what motivates
me which is that's true.
And so why wouldn't you live
like you only have one life.
Go ahead.
- [Man 7] So when was
that moment for you?
'Cause for me I know exactly
what it was and was there a
moment where it was
like a lightbulb?
- Where I was optimistic
in the way you were?
'Cause mine's the same.
I was in the dorm room my
freshman year of college in 1994
and I saw the internet and I
was like oh my God and I'd never
owned a computer and I've been
on a 28 hours of my life because
I was an F student and I didn't
even know what the internet was
I said something like is
information superhighway?
I didn't know what was going on.
I just knew right away that my
life had changed at that moment
but I also think there's a
lot of different things.
Guys, I have a book that I'm
writing that I'll eventually put
out called "I Wish Everyone Was
An Immigrant" and it's not too
different than what I told D
over there in corner which is
it's an advantage.
I have an advantage that all
my grandparents died in Russia
except for one.
Everybody died in Russia, do
you know why everybody died in
Russia at 50 and 55 and 60?
Because nobody wanted to live.
Do you know what Communism is?
They didn't want to live.
All my grandparents, both
my grandfathers went to jail
because they were Jewish.
'Cause it was
post-World War II Europe.
And I don't mean jail like
locked up for the night
I mean 10 years.
I feel like I came out the womb
knowing I was born in a shit
place I got lucky as hell to
come to America, my mom is the
greatest person on
earth and she parented me.
My dad taught me not to be
full of shit and that saved me.
I think that moments been
in my heart from the get
to be honest with you.
- Think we got
time for one more.
- How about that lady
all the way at the end,
let's go with her.
You, yep. You.
I like how you turned around.
Who? Me?
- [Terri] Okay now you're all
probably gonna laugh
at this question.
It might be
somewhat superficial.
- What's your name?
- [Terri] Terri.
- Terri.
- [Terri] Number 651 wine on
a plane was my favorite
Wine Library TV episode,
what is yours?
- That's awesome, thank you.
My favorite episode
of Wine Library TV?
God.
This is a good opportunity to
reminisce about something that's
so near and dear to my heart.
I don't think about Wine Library
TV that often these days so
I thank you Terri.
It's funny how like not
as serious as everything else
but you just brought
me a lot of happiness.
I love the episode when I
did it outside in the snow.
Because that was a fun episode
to get a little nerdy for you
Scoble and the others that was
my first episode to make the
front page of digg.com and if
you remember that was such a big
deal for the internet if you
get on digg that was like
(impersonates exploding sound)
that got me a lot.
I love the episode that I had
with Jim Cramer from "Mad Money"
because everybody was calling
me the Jim Cramer of wine.
I thought that was a funny meme.
AJ's first episode when he
turned 21 that something,
the fact that me and my brother
in 40 years can sit down and
with all of our grandkids put
on a screen or wherever
we're living in those days and
show them an episode
of AJ turning 21, super cool.
The episodes with my
dad were super fun to me.
Again, similar stuff when he's
gone I can have that content.
You know what?
My favorite episode
was the episode where
I ate all those different foods.
The first episode
to go really viral.
I ate like dirt and
cereal and cherries.
That episode caught the
attention of Conan O'Brien's
producers and then I did
Conan and you have to
remember this Scoble, right?
This was 2007.
- [Robert] Stinky socks.
- That's right, socks, dirt.
Conan O'Brien's producers
emailed me and said we'd like
you to do the
Conan O'Brien show.
Now this is 2007 most people
don't even know what
YouTube is yet, right?
I looked very careful at the
email address because I thought
it was my friends
playing a joke on me.
(audience laughter)
I emailed them back,
I held my breath, it was real.
This is how tight knit the
entire internet community was in
2007, I announce that I'm
going to be on Conan
the whole internet had my back.
Gruber from Daring Fireball,
Boing Boing, Digg, Reddit,
everybody.
All of the few people that
were on Twitter at that point,
everybody.
I felt, I don't know if I've ever
felt more professional pressure
than being in the green room
looking at Twitter and this
again 2007 early and just seeing
basically the entire Web 2.0 and
remember I referenced it earlier
tonight, I was a newcomer to it.
I was this kind of
different thing
and they all rallied behind me.
iJustine and Ze Frank and these
early video bloggers they all
were like you did it for us.
You're going to be on.
A video blogger on the Conan
show and I was sitting there
I was like and I had
never been on TV.
So like here I am never been
on TV and I'm going on this big
stage and what I found out later
Conan doesn't, I didn't know
this, I didn't know there was
anybody who did it different,
Conan doesn't rehearse.
When I went on to do the
Today Show and Dr. Oz and
Ellen Degeneres and all that,
they rehearsed.
Conan's improv.
Luckily, I ended up being improv
but I didn't know
that about myself.
Literally, I'm just like sitting
there behind this curtain just
like this and they're like your
go out in three, two and
I'm saying shit I have to
deliver big for the whole
Web 2.0, video blogging
community, not just for me.
I get pushed out I don't know
if any of you have seen it,
it crushed. I got Conan to
eat dirt, he's unbelievable.
I probably get paid the best
compliment I'll ever get paid
which was it ends,
the crowd goes crazy.
Conan turns to me, I didn't
realize how notoriously tough
Conan was on his guests.
These are I learned later in
life he looks he goes
that was phenomenal.
He goes so where do you perform?
And I go what?
He goes where do
you do your act?
And I was like oh
I'm not a comedian.
I'm a wine guy.
He goes get the fuck out here.
(audience laughter)
(applause)
And so I would say the
cereal I think it was like 148.
Maybe the cereal, the dirt, the
cigar because that became the
blueprint for the Today Show,
Ellen Denegeres, Conan which no
question gave me even more
street cred in the web community
which led to a very
big change in my life.
- Was that an
amazing 90 minutes?
(applause)
- Thank you Birmingham.
Thank you so much.
I love you guys.
Thank you.
(applause)
- [Man] Gary's gonna sign
a few books so you can
catch y'all in the lobby.
- [Gary] See you in the lobby.